All right, he's the comic
whose latest book is,
Hey Mom: Stories for My Mother,
But You Can Read Them Too,
whose new comedy special
Big Underwear is on Amazon,
who is the Emmy-winning star
of Baskets,
take a look.
I don't wanna look bad on TV.
KEN: You won't.
-I'm a rodeo-owner. (CHUCKLES)
-I know.
Can you believe it?
Christine,
why don't you just go out
and buy something new, honey?
I've already tried everything on
at The Dress Barn.
-(KEN SIGHS)
-I'm in between sizes.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Well, please welcome
my old friend Louie Anderson!
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
Louie, it's been too long!
-I love you, Bill.
-BILL: I love you too.
-How are you?
-Hi, everybody!
BILL: Louie Anderson.
-(CHEERING CONTINUES)
-Thank you so much.
-(WHISTLING)
-Thank you!
-Louie...
-I do not want Trump
messing with Amazon
till my book is off
the Best Seller list.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Please, Donald. Please.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Well, Louie, it's been
such an argumentative show.
-It has been.
But it's been good.
-And I--
-Oh, well...
-I loved the piece with Geraldo.
'Cause I love that you stuck
to your guns,
-and I love that you still are--
You still like Geraldo.
-(APPLAUSE)
-Yeah, absolutely. Well--
-Yeah.
-And I think we have to not--
-You know who else--
-Who I like is Roseanne!
-I love Roseanne. I--
And congratulations, Roseanne!
-Yes, congratulations. Yes.
-We can say that.
-You know, people got shit.
-I mean--
My friend Sarah Silverman
got shit for congratulating
Roseanne,
-it's ridiculous
that we can't even--
-And it's crazy.
And Roseanne is crazy.
Yes, but that's beside
the point.
-Beside the point, exactly.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(BILL LAUGHS)
Everybody has someone crazy
in their family.
-Sometimes it's you.
-Yes! (CHUCKLES) Well. Oh. Oh.
-No, I mean you're--
-No, I get it. I get it.
(BILL LAUGHS)
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
I get it.
I'm so happy to be here.
I miss you.
I haven't seen you in so long.
-I know.
-We know each other
a very, very long time.
Since the early, early days
of The Comedy Store,
when we were gonna write that...
-It wasn't--
-...that sitcom or something,
-weren't we?
-Yes, we did. We--
Was it Brothers,
or Buddies, or...?
We did, we tried to write
a sitcom together once.
You were gonna be
a conservative.
-No.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-(BILL CHUCKLES)
-I'm sorry.
-Cheap joke.
-But, um, look,
congratulations on every--
-I mean, you're always working,
I swear.
-Thank you.
And you do so many
different things, you know,
you were a gameshow host,
and now you've got
this brilliant,
Emmy-winning performance,
-and that is your mother
you're doing, right?
-Yes.
-And that--
-That is Ora Zella Anderson.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
-Okay.
-Love you, Mom.
-(APPLAUSE)
And the book is
about your mother, I mean,
she's kinda your hero, because
she-- she helped to step in
between you and your-- your
bad father, right? Bad father.
Yeah, yeah. You know, drunken,
you know, so...
-I forgive him, but drunken.
-Yes. Yeah.
And, you know, 11 children,
and she stood
between him and us, and...
-BILL: Right.
-...she saved us.
I mean, she--
she deflected, and--
and protected, and--
and then also fed us,
which, uh... really was,
you know,
-why I'm so fat, is because--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Well, no, it's true though.
-I wasn't gonna mention it.
Well... (CHUCKLES)
It's the elephant in the room.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Um...
-It's not...
-(APPLAUSE)
Oh.
Uh... No, but you know,
I don't mean to say that
she was bad by feeding us,
-but when things were rough...
-BILL: Right.
-...afterwards,
"Here, have some soup."
-BILL: Comfort food?
-Yeah, comfort food. Yeah.
-BILL: Yeah. Yeah.
I miss her, I love her, and, uh,
she-- she really has made
this character come to life.
I'm so happy she has
a starring role on TV.
Yeah. And playing--
A man playing a woman,
-has anybody given you any shit
for taking a job from a woman?
-No.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
'Cause-- No, that goes on
all the time now.
Yeah, yeah. No, I--
-You dare not play--
-I never thought of--
Until you said that,
I really had never
thought of it,
-because I am--
-BILL: Oh, oh. I don't wanna
start trouble.
Well, I don't mind, I don't...
I just think that
I agree, I understand that thing
but this is a comedy.
-BILL: Right.
-We're not--
-You know, that we're trying
to make a comedy, and I would--
-I know, I-- Okay.
If I was just a guy there,
it would be terrible playing.
-(CHUCKLES)
-But I know what you mean. I--
-Do not try to explain logic...
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you're right.
-...to the purity police.
-Yes, I won't.
-They just wanna be mad.
-Yes, that's true.
-They just--
They wanna be mad.
Why doesn't a woman
get that part?
-(CHUCKLES)
-Because that woman is not
funny, so she can't have it,
-the woman who's gonna play it.
-Right. Right.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-You know, can I just say this?
-You could--
Uh... Zach wanted a woman.
He had her picked out.
Brenda was a British actress,
I never can remember her name,
I should call and thank her,
but, um, she was busy,
and she couldn't do the part.
And then Zach said,
"I have an idea of a voice,"
and he said the voice,
and somebody said,
"It sounds like Louie Anderson."
"Aah," Zach went like that,
and he went, "Call him,"
and they called me,
and that's really
how I got the part.
Screw Judi Dench, huh?
-(CHUCKLES) Yeah.
-(APPLAUSE)
Um...
So, uh, I read that
you cry every day.
Yeah. I-- I was...
-Tell me about that,
'cause I-- I am not a cryer.
-Um...
You know when I cry?
I cry at movies.
-Yes.
-It's so easy to get me
to cry at a movie,
and so hard in life.
What does that say about me?
-Um...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Let's talk about me, Louie.
-I think--
Yeah, I would guess that
that would say about you is
that you're extremely
vulnerable.
-I mean, that you're--
-To movies.
-No, to...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
No, but that you're
a vulnerable person...
-Oh.
-...and crying would leave you--
'Cause you're, you know,
you would be wide open
on that front,
and that could be where--
Maybe that's where--
But how do you--
How do you get yourself
to cry every day?
Um...
You just think
of something sad?
No, I'll be talking, you know,
like, on the book tour
I've talked about my brother
-who is no longer with us...
-BILL: Okay, okay.
-...and, you know, I just,
I miss him. I miss him.
-BILL: That's sad.
I miss him, it's sad.
And also, you know we talk about
everything that's going on in--
Right now, the girl who shot up
the YouTube thing?
-BILL: Right.
-You know, we, as--
You know, I have mental illness
in my family, and...
-BILL: Right.
-We used to have safeguards
for mental illness.
There used to be hospitals
and places and checking on,
in a neighborhood,
when things went bad,
we knew the police,
we were connected,
we have stopped being connected
-as human beings.
-That's so true.
-We are not connected.
-(APPLAUSE)
And if my...
If our neighbors were doing
something across the street...
-BILL: Right.
-...my dad went,
"What the-- Huh?"
-(BILL LAUGHS)
-Honestly. "What are they doing
over there?"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And he would call someone
who'd go over there,
"What are you doing over here?"
Yeah.
"You can't have 100 guns
in here."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-But we-- we...
(BILL STUTTERS, CHUCKLES)
I don't mean you should do that.
I don't--
We don't want that either,
right?
-We don't want people--
-Well, no, but you want this.
-But you want--
-You want a little of that,
but not too--
You want your mom going,
"Well, I'll call Shirley,
-'cause she knows the sheriff,
and she'll--"
-BILL: Right, exactly.
-BILL: Well--
-We were connected,
we knew the police.
There was a-- there was
a book once, called
It Takes a Village...
-Yes.
-...and that's what
that was about.
-Yes.
-Of course.
-That's a wonderful book.
-It was.
That the right wing hated.
-Yes. Yeah, what is that?
-Because it was socialism!
-You know, my--
-But really, it was just
neighbors helping neighbors.
And it really is.
And you know, all of us,
if, right now,
something happened,
all of us would band together
to help each other,
so why do we need to wait
till something happens?
Well-- Or we'd band together
and eat each other.
-I mean, you don't--
you don't know...
-That's true.
-I mean...
-You know who'd be go--
they'd kill first.
-(BILL LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)